you in the car she turn around and go oh
touch nothing don't look at nothing
don't ask for nothing or you get an
ass-whupping he's gonna lose this pair
of black cards today first of all the
Carlton banks over here I'm just hoping
we at least keep one car I feel like
cats have nine lives
I feel like we should get more than one
black card their levels to black man you
lose a new window card you're still
playing you know games not over you
wanna do well it's rise like soy milk
food free what here are your black box
oh that's been it's been through some
things well yes it's a black oh now I'm
scared to lose it
[Music]
well the anxiety I'm not a good test
taker guys but stop drop shut them down
open up shop you gonna stop it's gonna
drop set them down over their mouths
shut the thing is there are several a
multi-faceted question now if you give
you them with please stop and get a
camera I have no idea what any of that
is we've got a friend is this from the
Bible no you know I bring the sound like
in minded Brenda had a baby I think you
see em I just wrote what you want see
cuz I know it ain't deep Apollonia is a
Kanye West line I don't know what he's
referencing or what it is but I'm just
gonna go with that cuz I don't know god
is good
I asked me was the Bible verse and God
heard me and so he said it's not the
Holy Spirit God but blessed be thank you
oh this is easy I kinda want to test it
out I want to be introduced to him and
if he like doesn't open up and tell me
kind of like ya fears and all of his
trauma
it's like credit card numbers yeah like
I want to see what future will do you're
gonna I won't fight you how do you give
you give us all black people you if I
have to be over the Asian like 50 get
down
I mean I'll put up see cuz she said is
it fight oh if we imagine though just um
lets you see a in the car it's a car
that should turn off the turn off the
car look back don't ask for nothing
don't look at nothing
do not touch anything
in that order although that yeah yeah
it's like what you don't look at it but
you can touch it yeah yeah definitely
oh you love so you got a how to love yes
I touch it nothing do you do it a little
bit
no you ain't right I'm gonna go with a B
and C if you like you like grape grape
drink not really what black people do
I'm gonna [ __ ] what you think and buy
like fried chicken but wheezing he
flexing it better than anybody I guess
fried chicken and grape drink I will say
that my authentic stereotypical black
self love me some project I think I
would say be gluing Fried Chicken live
and die by the bird that's why they
don't think you like that man that's
fine that's a sequence yeah yeah cuz it
was a lot depending on who you [ __ ]
wait oh that's hard by everybody for all
the B's
oh no aim the Patel sale is the staple
of a click cookout I might have to go
with walking in and I speaking cuz you
you don't gotta bring something every
time cuz some people know you to can't
cook I personally don't like potato
salad I serenade during space are you
kidding
yeah I plug you I think you could get
shot for the other are you walking you
see grandma you just you just don't say
that and you brought somebody I mean it
don't even matter your attitude they
don't matter hi no no ya don't walk in
is you TV smiling but you better open
your mouth mom I pretty sure I said this
to me like in Somali like really it's a
universal language is a universal
language
it's do you got parents language no
matter your black bomba turn around sit
straight up you don't you gonna need
some bu Annie's a McDonald's money
anything does anything not yeah I was
gonna say like ma can I give you a tweet
but I have some damn toy money oh ma I
go here you better have some here money
my mom proud coming up you got prom
money you got field trip much it's three
dollars mom pipe down
it's a universal thing everyone knows
that think they give it soon as you
birth the black child
I'm booked and the first page it says
repeat at every acceptable situation oh
there you gotta say it to your babies
too oh yeah Formula One yeah I hear you
crying
you got diaper money right it's those
good to know that my black card is able
to be uh don't you for the day
did you ever doubt that we were gonna
have them revoked no this is dumb I
don't think I'm always getting cussed
out or not speaking at a cookout because
especially in 2018 cardi B already
addressed you and I don't speak it means
I don't [ __ ] with you
[Music]